[Music]
was there ever a time where you saw a
cartoon and thought it would be amazing
to live in it there are people in this
world who are very fortunate to live in
or visit these cartoon themed houses
that look like the real thing from the
inside as well as the outside how
awesome does that spongebob squarepants
house look if you enjoyed our video and
want more click the subscribe button
today we're exploring amazing houses
inspired by your favorite cartoons The
Simpsons let's start with one of the
most popular houses out there did you
know that the exact replica of the
Simpsons house was built in Henderson
Nevada the entire construction cost one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars and
it pretty much resembled the real
Simpsons house from the inside and out
the exact bright orange and yellow
colors on its exterior made this house
stand out from the rest and the decor
inside was equally as impressive matte
gray mean the creator of the show
himself showed up at the house and drew
a portrait of Homer Simpson in the
concrete along with his handprints and
his name the house was actually a part
of the Simpsons house giveaway a contest
run by Pepsi Fox and the home builder
imagine getting a chance to live in your
own version of the Simpsons house pretty
cool right well the winner of the
giveaway opted out for a seventy-five
thousand dollar cash prize instead what
happened to the house it's now a part of
a commercial real estate that has
unfortunately been painted over with
much more settled colors however the
Simpson legacy lives on and the portrait
of Homer Simpson can still be seen on
the concrete pathway leading to the
front door spongebob squarepants ever
wondered what it's really like to live
in the pineapple under the sea well
unlike the Simpson house you can
actually live in this one yourself and
don't worry it's not located under the
sea it's actually based in the new
Nickelodeon Hotel and Resort in Punta
Cana in the Dominican Republic and yes
it's the exact replica of the famous
SpongeBob SquarePants
pineapple house on the outside
what to enter the pineapple it gets even
better the spongebob house is a two
bedroom duplex suite with an awesome
infinity pool tributes to the popular
cartoon can be found in every single
room this includes the pet snail Gary
you can find in the exact spongebob
living room replicas we are also in love
with the theme details of the house
really giving an impression that you've
entered the unique underwater world of
Sponge Bob the coffee table that looks
like a sponge the exact TV from the show
the outside rain shower it will all
remind you of Sponge Bob Squarepants the
villa also comes with a private butler
who will bring you any food you desire
including Krabby Patties guests also get
spongebob theme surprises throughout
Thursday including food from the show
I'm Jay Packers SquarePants and head to
the dominican republic sign us up The
Jetsons it's hard to believe someone
could actually recreate the modern
cartoon world of the Jetsons right
well brace yourselves because the
Jetsons house just became a reality The
Jetsons actually inspired a lot of mid
21st century architecture that focused
on so-called floating houses and
apartments much like the ones you see in
the popular cartoon check out this home
designed by John Lautner that looks like
it could just take off any minute it's
called the Kimo sphere designed in 1960
two years before the Jetsons first aired
the Kimo sphere can be found in LA it
sits on a hill 30 feet above the city
and we bet it offers spectacular views
the house was actually a part of many
movies including Charlie's Angels the
similar-looking house was also seen in
the Simpsons where it was used by a
fictional pop star the inspiration for
the Jetsons also came from Los Angeles
International Airport if you look at it
from the distance it really does look
like a Jetsons inspired structure the
Flintstones it sounds crazy but it's the
truth
the beloved cave house settled in the
famous cartoon town of bedrock is now a
reality and it's also on sale based in
Hillsboro California this house is one
of the most unique designs first built
in 1976 it's a modern upgrade to the
Flintstones home but it holds its theme
by using non-traditional building
materials in a
experimental architecture the
bubble-like domes in stone exterior
really give it a feel of a unique
Flintstones inspired home the inside of
the house is pretty awesome too we love
how the cave walls combined with modern
architecture but one of the most amazing
features is the kitchen
check out the unique skylight in the
Flintstones inspired shelves the dome
ceilings made of stone really make you
feel like you're in your very own
Flintstones home all you need now is
space for Dino and you're sorted
although there's no proof that the home
builders got inspired by the Flintstones
it's safe to say the home does look like
we're modern Fred and Wilma Flintstone
would actually stay in in 2011 a home
building company decided to recreate the
up house and the results were very
fascinating this one-of-a-kind building
is reconstructed in Harriman Utah the
company really managed to bring the up
house back to life with the white picket
fence the weathervane and the colorful
exterior that automatically brings a
smile to your face everything looks the
same from the inside also the wallpapers
the furniture the frame photos it all
makes you feel like you're gonna true-up
house but there's another house based in
Seattle but the curious visitors
nicknamed the up house
although Pixar denied it had any
connection to the movie fans continue to
call it the up house it has a unique
place between two very tall buildings
and it belongs to Edith Masefield a
world war two spy she refused a
million-dollar offer from the shopping
complex next door to sell the house
although Edith passed away and nobody's
really sure what to do with this house
her story is finally being heard her so
called up Thomas plays an important part
in a movie in a memoir based on Edith's
life and although Pixar denies the
connection to the movie up a local
publicist actually fixed balloons onto
the fence to promote the original movie
Minnie Mouse everyone knows Minnie Mouse
right the cute always happy Mouse
dressed in pink
she's also Mickey Mouse's girlfriend and
a close friend of Daffy Duck but do you
remember where she lived
maybe Disney's toontown fair will help
you remember Disney Land put together an
exact replica of the Minnie Mouse house
and its
stunning the house is uniquely designed
and the eye-popping colors used really
bring The Adventures of Minnie Mouse
back to life the interior is just as
magical as the exterior you can find
unique cartoon like pieces of furniture
you're able to sit on in use the
old-fashioned radio fireplace
a sewing machine and a fridge with
nothing in it but cheese the fashionable
kitchen has functioning objects designed
in the Minnie Mouse world style but
there's a whole lot more things to
explore the backyard even has Pluto's
doghouse and his bone and the backyard
pathway leads to the real-life version
of Mickey and Minnie ready to meet you
beware there's a lot of pink the house
is always a hit with kids and we could
totally see why Disney really outdid
themselves with this unique replica
Barbie almost every child is given a
Barbie doll to play with if you're lucky
enough you get a very big dollhouse and
enter the Barbie world but did you know
you can do that in real life too pink
stilettos a Wardrobe full of clothes
pink colored house a pink kitchen where
you can bake virtual cupcakes a
real-life Barbie doll house was set in
Berlin in 2013 although just an
exhibition this peak perfect world was a
one-of-a-kind chance to enter the real
Barbie doll house spread over 25,000
square feet the house had absolutely
everything to offer but focus on what
Barbie really represented one of the
biggest messages Barbie dolls portray is
that you can do absolutely anything you
set your mind to the doll house allowed
kids to get styled in the in-house salon
and play games on led touch screens they
were also able to digitally try on some
fashion items and really experience the
pink world in which every Barbie doll
lives but it's not the only real-life
Barbie doll house the signature pink
house also opened in Florida and the
magical project was called the dream
house experience The Hobbit the
enchanting house from The Hobbit really
looks like the real thing
Satan wheels this building was designed
by an architect Diamond Dale who claims
he spent anywhere from a thousand to
1,500 hours building the house the fairy
tale-like house is dug into a hillside
which is not only eco-friendly but also
creates an enchanting atmosphere
they'll use stone and mud for retaining
walls and oak thinning for the frame the
house comes with an amazing skylight
which lets in natural light and a solar
panel for electricity the interior also
looks like a house from a fairy tale
with a fireplace library area twinkle
lights and an upper floor the home is
completely natural and continues to go
viral on social media it seems like just
about everyone wants their own version
of the hobbit house and we could
definitely see why just check out the
beautiful living area and the enchanting
wooden staircase leading to the upper
floor daily inspired home builders
around the world and you are now able to
find many eco-friendly houses they
inspire more and more people to start
living in their own fairy tale version
Batman you may not be able to ever live
in the Gotham City but modern
architecture allows us to build houses
that easily resemble the homes from our
favorite cartoons but the actual Batman
inspired Batcave does exist and it's
just as majestic as you imagined it
would be the architects named it the
Wayne residence the absolutely majestic
house was built in 1928 and got
completely updated by a Batman superfan
here's the coolest part of the Wayne
residence the designers decided to use
the space 20 feet below and build a
garage that can hold an entire car
collection along with a 12 seat theater
the hydraulics to operate the garage are
pretty amazing
what's the tennis court on the top of
the garage lift up the car travels down
a concealed ramp into the garage which
also has LEDs and mirrored walls it's
pretty awesome and the whole process of
lifting up and lowering the tennis court
takes only about two minutes the garage
resembles the Batcave to a tee and
believe it or not it's even its upgraded
version check it out
the client who hasn't been named wanted
to maintain the houses heritage while
adding an underground lair of every
Batman fans dream this home can be found
in the exclusive neighborhood of Toorak
in Melbourne Australia Star Wars the
popular franchise has fans all over the
world and we think it deserves an
honorary mention on this list the world
of Star Wars is every fans dream woody
you want to live in a Star Wars theme
house it turns out Star Wars actually
inspired many
to your designers and house builders
around the world check out this
Millennium Falcon mansion in Australia
that looks exactly like the real
starship you can find this home on a
lake in the forests of Queensland close
to Cape Tribulation the Millennium
Falcon mansion was created by an
Australian designer in 2009 and is worth
fifteen million dollars the futuristic
Star Wars looking home is built 36 feet
above the water and is made out of
concrete steel and glass you won't be
able to find any real-life stormtroopers
in there but you'll find something much
more interesting three-car garages a
swimming pool uniquely shaped bedrooms
marble in bamboo bathrooms and more the
stunning Star Wars spaceship shaped home
even comes with a helipad an open-air
theatre and a wine cellar what do you
think would you want to live here other
Star Wars inspired houses include this
sandcrawler house in South Korea a Death
Star cabin in Catskills New York and the
Endor a walk tree house in Bali
Indonesia which cartoon house do you
wish would exist in real life let us
know in the comments below and don't
forget to like this video want more
check out the video about ten cartoons
that look different in other countries
did your favorite cartoon make the list
[Music]